[Music]  it's time for et social study a quick  look at what stars are posting online  Queen Elizabeth celebrates her sapphire  Jubilee with a gorgeous new portrait and  the perfect accessory her Majesties  stunned in a sky blue gown and sapphire  jewelry to ring in her 65th year on the  British throne from drunk tweets to  wardrobe malfunctions Chrissy Teigen had  an eventful Sunday at the Super Bowl  Crissy suffered a nip slip after going  braless to the championship game with  her husband John Legend one Twitter user  pointed out the models Nipplegate and  she had the best response writing boom  goes the dynamite  in Patriots were touchdown meanwhile Tom  Brady's wife Gisele Bundchen can't  contain her excitement after her husband  won his fifth Super Bowl ring  Giselle's reaction to the Patriots  victory is the best thing we've seen all  day I'm very lucky